jay's in atlanta hi jay welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey dave hey christy how are you hi guys
great how can we help
well dave i'm in need of some mortgage
pay off therapy
thank you for your honesty we're ready
for it all right stretch out here on the
couch
i logged on today got the about to hit
submit to pay off the balance and just
hesitated and
had a panic attack i'm like i'm going to
call dave and see what he thinks
okay so how much do you how much do you
own the mortgage
uh just shy of 260 so 259 you have the
money in the account to pay it off
i do and how much other money other than
that do you have
uh that'll leave me 140
000 in cash and what do you make a year
50
short term well that's where it gets
tricky i'm just exiting
my position so technically i am
unemployed
okay what are you gonna do i haven't
decided yet but i'm gonna
jump back into the market at some point
um
but i'm haven't decided but there won't
be anything coming in for a
few months at least so um
so i think that's my hesitancy and uh i
mean if
because you are without an income if you
want to sit on the cash for a little bit
that's fine conceptually though
if you were employed would you have had
the hesitation
no i would not okay well
you know figure out what you're going to
do in a couple of months 60 90 days land
on it
and i got a feeling you're a guy making
a couple hundred or more right
yes yeah what'd you make before
uh 250 plus yeah what's your what's your
field
uh technology yeah okay so this is you
can do this again right right
yes if you find the right place the
right group of people and you're not
dealing with a bunch of idiots and you
know you know all that kind of thing
you'd land again
and and cash in a 250 chip again and go
go have some fun with some people you
want to work with right
that's exactly right yeah but you know
you're not going to jump you're not
desperate you're not going to jump into
a toxic situation you got a pile of cash
um if anything happens you can reach
over and pay it off instantaneously
i'm okay if you sit on it for 69 days
while you land somewhere
but over the scope of your life if
you're employed pay the stupid thing off
yeah yeah and your credit's good right
yeah outstanding yeah so if you've got
good credit and you've got a job and you
pay off your mortgage and you hate it
we'll go get you another mortgage
but nobody ever does that
thanks for the call brother